j'ai le sentiment que vous fichez vous
avoue être outré par cette audition qui
assiste à une mascarade on est dans un
film répondez à rien du tout
[Musique]
croyez bien que l'ensemble des
collaborateurs
d'orpea en france ont été absolument
bouleversés et meurtri par les
allégations de ce livre parler de
révélation dans le livre permettez moi
de vous suggérer allégations je crois
que c'est plus précis nous ne nions pas
qu'il peut y avoir des
dysfonctionnements on vous l'a dit
ce que nous ne comprenons pas c'est que
bien sûr ce soit décrit comme une
volonté multiples témoignages tout au
long du livre montre que l'augmentation
du nombre de lits et la diminution du
nombre de soignants et de médecins
conduisent mécaniquement à des
situations dramatiques de maltraitance
nous signalons aux agences régionales de
santé et au département toute suspicion
de maltraitance je serai le premier à
venir présenter des excuses s'il y avait
des cas avérés c'est un tout petit
nombre de cas par rapport aux personnes
qui sont résidente j'aimerais savoir
dans le groupe orpea combien de cdd sont
en cours à l'heure actuelle parce que on
sait très bien que plus on a recours à
des cdd très souvent ça atteint la
qualité il ya des personnes qui ne
souhaite plus avoir un cdi il ya des
personnes qui souhaitent de travailler
qu'en cdd quand je faisais 38 cdd à la
même personne dans la même année
ce n'était pas par volonté de ne pas
l'embaucher
c'était la volonté de cette personne de
ne pas avoir un cdi séminaire en station
de sports d'hiver courchevel megève
stadt hôtel luxueux et resteront très
prisé aides financières à des
personnalités politiques influentes
monsieur le président les familles les
français veulent savoir à quoi employés
voulaient milliers les millions d'euros
que vous verse chaque mois les familles
des résidants qui parfois se sacrifie
pour vous rémunérer sista une mascarade
quand une famille vous verse entre 7000
et 12000 euros par mois alors que la
puissance publique vous a déjà payé une
partie des soins il me semble que les
résidents peuvent attendre des
prestations d'excellence voire même un
certain confort nous sommes dans une
activité profondément humaine ce sont
des services rendus par des êtres
humains à d'autres êtres humains comme
nous vous l'avons dit nous sommes tout à
fait ouverts à donner toutes les
réponses à vos questions et je crois que
de toute façon il ya beaucoup
d'insatisfactions puisque on n'a pas les
réponses attendues nous avons appris que
votre prédécesseur avait vendu près de
5500 actions de votre entreprise après
avoir été informés de l'enquêté en cours
ce qui me laisse un goût amer on veut
avoir des réponses sur cette stratégie
qui a été mise en place depuis des
années les plus belles entreprises sont
fragiles soyons très prudente et
détruire des entreprises sur la base
d'allégations c'est toujours possible
est vraiment dans le monde dans le monde
entier on a actuellement 70 mille
résidents dont nous prenons soin voilà
un très joli rush des merci bien
monsieur le président je tiens à vous
rassurer nous ne sommes pas là pour
détruire les entreprises nous sommes là
pour veiller effectivement à nos aînés
qu'ils soient bien bien accompagné
jusqu'à leur fin de vie je vous avoue
être outré par cette audition par la
qualité ou l'absence de réponse sur un
certain nombre de sujets quand je
regarde les les les entrées les entrées
et les sorties dans les ehpad l'ap tout
de suite tout de suite pour un christ
est-ce qu'il ya par exemple des vagues
de départ d'anne aux ehpad eu égard à à
aux allégations mentionnées on pourrait
on pourrait le penser mais y'en a pas je
vous écoute depuis une heure et vous ne
répondez à rien du tout faut pas tourner
autour du pot vous êtes un peu là comme
le lapin pris dans les phares mais on
est dans un film lorsque vous prenez
l'air l'air un peu étonné j'ai
l'impression pour reprendre un truc de
zodiac faut pas prendre les enfants du
bon dieu pour des canards sauvages j'ai
le sentiment que vous fichez nous quand
vous parler d'humanisme vraiment on
arrêté là puisque la représentation
nationale je vous dis franchement vous
cache pas est déçu de la qualité de vos
réponses ou l'absence de réponse donc on
va arrêter là cet cette audition je ne
vous cache pas non plus bien sûr ma
déception
[Musique]